Black Adam has been the hardest work
I've ever put in my career and when I
tell you I went to work I went to work
completely different than what's going
on behind the scenes let's get into it
well I do number one something you might
think would be simple but was actually
incredibly difficult there was no
practical Dr Fate suit or cape on set he
never wore one it was all added in post
with CG Pierce Brosnan had to wear a
costume with a ton of tracking markers
all over him due to how much CGI was
going to be added to his body he truly
didn't even know what he would end up
looking like as Dr Fate one of the most
difficult aspects of this was blending
his body movements with the costume
especially because it was supposed to be
skin tight a major aspect they had to
work on was when he turns his head from
side to side or says certain syllables
when you see his Adam's Apple move it
was all meticulously computer generated
prepared
number two let's talk about black Adam's
introduction
the beginning of the movie when Adriana
calls Shazam and Black Adam appears
inside the rock of Eternity there is
some major VFX work going on when
they're inside the chamber to achieve
that sequence they photographed live
action props and the set in the
foreground but the rest of it was
entirely CG there were about 150 shots
in that sequence alone they were able to
pick and choose the shots they wanted
and put them all together by the end of
it number three a completely new type of
flight rig was created for Black Adam
apparently director Jean Colette Sarah
was determined to eliminate the
limitations of the usual flight stunts
you'd see in movies producer Hiram
Garcia talked with collider about how
important this technology was for the
film the technology we're using to make
Black Adam fly has never been done
before it's completely unique it was
critical for us to ensure that it felt
special authentic and real as well as
turned him around at a full 360 degree
angle I never got on any wires I was on
this real really cool Advanced machine
that allowed me to lay flat I think fans
will really appreciate the detail and
Nuance of how Black Adam is able to fly
with real rage and power and force
I just dropped him
number four sticking with black Adam's
appearance in the rock of Eternity there
was a scene that was majorly daunting
for the VFX supervisors the moment when
Black Adam grabs one of the mercenaries
by the neck and electrocutes him until
he dissolves and turns into Ash was one
of the most challenging shots they had
to get they had to blend the CGI effects
with an actual person not an alien or
Monster so the challenge was making it
look realistic like an actual human
being was being fried
number five some major brainstorming had
to be done to figure out what they would
look like on screen it was a man who is
bestowed with this power of the helmet
of Naboo which is kind of a blessing and
a curse due to his powers being so
complex and important for the movie's
narrative they went back and forth with
some Stills and comic book shots between
the filmmakers and the visual effects
supervisors in order to figure out what
they were going to do what ended up
happening was some experimentation on a
completely different character a
sequence that unfortunately did not make
the cut before actually applying that CG
to Dr Fate
time for you and I
you and I you know
number six another CGI aspect that could
be overlooked when Black Adam first
appears in the rock of Eternity and the
mercenaries are shooting at him he's
wearing this big black cloak that's
being shredded to Pieces when they shot
it on set it was just Dwayne Johnson in
a cloak but nothing else was actually
happening so they had to go in and add a
bunch of Sparks coming off of him as
well as make the cloth react and Shred
to what was supposed to be going on they
even had to make sure you could see the
fibers in the cloth because it was shot
so close up
number seven this CGI effect was
actually one of the simpler things they
got to do when Black Adam enters
Adriana's apartment he doesn't use the
door he just goes through the wall the
artists who made this effect happen use
the program Houdini and were able to
crank it out relatively quickly they
managed to get the desired effect in
only one or two iterations of the scene
it does have a point
number eight at digital domain they use
a particular technology to create their
CG characters the tech is called
charlatan and they weren't even sure
they were going to use it when making
the film but wanted to get all the shots
in just in case
what that consists of is having the
actual actors on set and shooting them
from every angle you could imagine so
they could record and save certain
facial expressions they would then input
all of that into the computer so later
when they're animating the characters
they could apply any of those elements
at any moment to make them look more
photorealistic we won't see
it number nine what's going on behind
the scenes is vastly different from what
we see on screen let's talk about the
number of green screens used to make
this movie it's not super interesting
but ninety percent of the film was shot
in front of them the other 10 were LEDs
they had led content they had to create
with multiple vendors they had two
different LED stages One in Atlanta
Georgia and the other one in Los Angeles
California there were at least a dozen
visual effects Studios that helped
create the film's effects foreign
number 10 we all know lighting is one of
the most important things when shooting
a movie
one of the programs they used called
unreal allowed them to adjust the
lighting in real time usually after
shooting if you want to change the color
of the sky or location of the sun you
would have to edit it after and wouldn't
be able to see the results the next day
with unreal the artists were able to
adjust the lighting in real time and
play around with different colors and
effects which gave the production team a
major speed boost when it came to
getting everything done
look at that shoot it's cool thanks
thanks me too number 11 the movie
utilized All The Cutting Edge technology
money could buy Dwayne spilled some
behind the scenes secrets on Instagram
about the high-end technology that was
being used to capture his movements they
used a high-speed phantom camera that
was able to shoot him at 960 frames per
second which is insane compared to the
usual 24 frames per second used for most
movies operating at 40 times the usual
capture rate this was definitely not
your average movie setup
look alive to me because I saved them
number 12 people all over the world
worked on this movie a lot of the work
to create the visual effects were done
remotely there was a visual effects team
in Los Angeles Montreal Vancouver and
Hyderabad India
there were even individual artists
working in Germany Ontario Portland and
Florida because the film was shot during
the coveted pandemic everyone had the
option to work from home even those who
couldn't all of the time were able to do
a hybrid style of work they're only
Heroes and they're villains
you think yourself a hero
Black Adam uses New Age Technology a
Workforce from all over the world a
plethora of green screens and a talented
crew who really know their way around
digital effects throw in the incredible
Black Adam lore taken directly from the
comics what more could you want leave a
comment and let us know what your
favorite CGI moment was